ok computer hat die steuerung ich mache
gar nichts vorne kommt die kurve ist
langsamer geworden und funktioniert ich
habe nichts gemacht diesen autonomen um
die kurve gefahren
das auto mit dem ich hier fahren konnte
besitzt acht kameras einen radler und
zwölf ultraschall sensoren mit denen es
die umgebung ständig im blick behält
es erkennt sowohl die straße mit all
ihren markierungen und windungen als
auch andere verkehrsteilnehmer und
bremst sogar für diese so ein auto kann
man heute bereits kaufen das ist ein
level 2 auf der autonomie skala das
bedeutet dass der fahrer zu jedem
zeitpunkt bereit sein muss einzugreifen
das auto verlangt auch regelmäßig dass
man seine hände bitte ans steuer legen
soll
und das ist wirklich wichtig falls ihr
einmal mit einem solchen auto fahren
sollte man kann sich auf die technologie
noch nicht 100-prozentig verlassen also
seid bitte vorsichtig und achtet ständig
auf den verkehr
aber das wirft natürlich die frage auf
wann kann ich dann endlich ein auto
kaufen das komplett von alleine fährt
[Musik]
die meisten autos die heute auf der
straße fahren sind entweder level 0 oder
level 1 auf der autonomie skala level 0
bedeutet dass das auto keine intelligenz
besitzt und komplett vom fahrer
gesteuert wird ein normales auto eben
bei level 1 wird man als fahrer immerhin
schon durch dinge wie einen adaptiven
tempomaten oder einen automatischen
spurhalte assistenten unterstützt das
fahren muss aber immer noch von einem
menschen gemacht werden
level 2 ist das was ich testen konnte
das auto fährt an und für sich von
alleine
ich muss aber zu jedem zeitpunkt bereits
sein einzugreifen da das system
jederzeit die kontrolle abgeben kann
wenn es nicht weiter weiß
das ist übrigens auch mehrfach passiert
bekommt die kurve deswegen hier noch mal
passt bitte ständig auf wenn ihr solche
features benutzt autonomie level 3 ist
ziemlich umstritten denn das auto
übernimmt das fahren selbständig und
erlaubt den fahrer sogar sich vom
verkehr abzuwenden also zum beispiel
aufs handy zu gucken oder sogar
zeitungen zu lesen
aber sobald etwas passiert mit denen das
system nicht fertig wird muss der mensch
eingreifen können das problem ist nur
dass wir menschen uns nicht sofort in
eine situation hinein finden können wenn
man abgelenkt ein youtube-video guckt
und das auto plötzlich kippt weil es vor
sich ein objekt wahrnimmt dass es nicht
wieder erkennen kann
dann brauchen wir erst mal einen moment
um uns zurechtzufinden diesen einen
moment hat man aber im zweifel nicht und
schon kracht es deswegen überspringen
einige hersteller dieses level und
arbeiten direkt an level 4
denn level 4 und 5 sind das was wir
unter einem wirklich autonomen auto
verstehen beide level fahren komplett
autonom und dürfen sogar ohne menschen
im auto fahren
der einzige unterschied ist dass level 4
manche situationen wie zum beispiel
heftige wetterbedingungen nicht
beherrscht während ein theoretisches
level-5 fahrzeug in jeder situation
fahren kann
in der auch ein mensch fahren könnte im
notfall muss ein level 4 system immer
rechtzeitig anhalten bevor es in eine
situation gerät die es nicht bewältigen
kann
da laut adac aktuell mehr als 90 prozent
der unfälle auf menschliches versagen
zurückzuführen sind erhofft man sich von
autonomen autos einen sicheren
straßenverkehr
aber wie funktioniert überhaupt ein
selbst fahrendes auto der kern dieser
technologie ist künstliche intelligenz
genauer gesagt neuronale netze
die wurden vom menschlichen gehirn
inspiriert und funktionieren ganz anders
als herkömmliche computer programme um
sie zu trainieren macht mir nämlich
dasselbe was man auch mit menschlichen
fahranfängern macht erst zeigt man ihnen
wie man richtig fährt und dann lässt man
sie natürlich unter beaufsichtigung
selber fahren wenn ihr mehr darüber
erfahren wollt wie neuronale netze
aufgebaut sind und funktionieren dann
schaut euch gerne einmal dieses video
hier von mir an wie bereits erwähnt gibt
es verschiedene sensoren die um das auto
herum angebracht sind und ständig die
umgebung beobachten dass es mehrere
arten von sensoren gibt hat natürlich
einen guten grund jeder art sensor hat
nämlich ihre ganz spezifischen stärken
und schwächen
eine kamera zum beispiel kann farben
wahrnehmen und man kann mit ihr gut
objekte identifizieren aber sobald es
dunkel wird hat sie probleme ein
radarsensor funktioniert wiederum
wunderbar in der dunkelheit und kann
sogar an manchen hindernissen vorbei
schauen hat aber gleichzeitig eine
schlechte auflösung indem man
verschiedene sensoren mischt sorgt nicht
nur dafür dass man alle nötigen bereiche
abdeckt sondern kann unter
normalbedingungen auch doppelt und
dreifach sicher gehen dass man ein
objekt richtig erkennt wenn sowohl die
kamera als auch das radar als auch die
ultraschall sensoren melden dass da
vorne auf der straße etwas zu sein
scheint dann kann man sich recht sicher
sein dass das auch stimmt
ein heißes thema in der branche ist
aktuell übrigens leider dieser laser
basierte sensor kann sowohl weit gucken
als auch entfernungen genau abmessen ist
aber aktuell noch recht teuer und
sperrig trotzdem findet man leider
sensoren an den autonomen fahrzeugen von
fast jedem großen player fasst
geschäftsführer von tesla allen masc ist
so ziemlich der einzige der behauptet
auch ohne leider auskommen zu können
viel mehr noch er ist sogar der meinung
dass alle die auf leider setzen zum
scheitern verurteilt sind aber nicht nur
hier steht tesla alleine da auch in den
voraussagen für die zukunft macht macht
wie üblich ein paar sehr aggressive
ansagen bei gästen
hewitt punktet save for service century
forestry wake up the nation friedrich
sexier experten sind diese aussage
gegenüber extrem kritisch eingestellt
nicht zuletzt weil ihnen maske selten
seine selbstgesteckten zeitplan einhält
eigentlich wollte der tesla chef bis
ende 2017 einem komplett autonomen trip
von der küste der usa zu anderen
vorweisen können bis heute konnte er
nicht liefern
die meisten anderen hersteller wie ford
und volkswagen sind inzwischen
wesentlich nüchterner als noch vor
wenigen jahren als geschäftsführer jim
hackett sagte kürzlich zum beispiel dass
sie die ankunft autonome fahrzeuge
überschätzt haben
huber hat anscheinend von anfang an
nicht an ihre eigenen hochgesteckten
ziele geglaubt und gm cruz haben ihr
ursprüngliches ziel noch dieses jahr
einen selbst fahrenden taxi service zu
starten auf unbestimmte zeit verschoben
selbst fahrende taxi services gibt es
allerdings schon in mehreren städten in
den vereinigten staaten kann man bereits
heute in selbstfahrenden autos fahren
allerdings sind an dieser aussage zwei
sternchen zum einen sitzt trotzdem noch
ein sicherheitsfahrer hinter dem lenkrad
der kann und soll vor allem zu jederzeit
eingreifen können falls etwas
unerwartetes passiert zum anderen sind
die gebiete in denen die autos fahren
können recht kleinen auf der website von
der google-tochter whale liest man dass
diese gebiete extra für selbstfahrende
autos ausgemessen und teilweise per hand
aufbereitet werden so wissen die autos
immer genau wo sie sich befinden und das
macht es wiederum schwierig diese autos
als wirklich autonom zu bezeichnen wenn
erst jede strecke auf der ein autonomes
autofahren soll auch wenn ich von einem
menschen eingetragen werden muss dann
dauert es lange bis wir überall herum
fahren können gamer gibt aktuell keine
auskunft darüber wann das projekt in die
nächste phase gehen soll
brian chesky ist sogar noch verhalten
haben er ist geschäftsführer von ago i
einem start-up das sowohl für ford als
auch für vw selbst fahrende technologien
entwickelt er sagte bei einem interview
mit der new york times das
selbstfahrende autos die überall
hinfahren könnten noch zitat sehr weit
in der zukunft liegen
das problem seien die vielen unüblichen
dinge die einem auf der straße begegnen
eine herde schafe oder hühner
rollstuhlfahrer die wild im kreis fahren
oder einfach nur die müllabfuhr die
einen dazu zwingt kurz auf der
gegenfahrbahn zu fahren das ist das
problem mit selbstfahrenden autos sind
sie also wirklich noch viele jahre
entfernt nun das hängt so ein bisschen
davon ab wie man glaubt der ganzen
branche oder elon musk
einen vorteil hat tesla nämlich daten
und wenn es um künstliche intelligenz
geht sind daten alles seit 2015 sind
alle hergestellten teslas mit den
kameras rada und ultraschallsensoren für
autonomes fahren ausgestattet worden
außerdem haben die autos eine aktive
internetverbindung jeder gefahrene
kilometer ob mit oder ohne autopilot
funktion hilft tesla seine neuronalen
netze zu trainieren und das dürften
inzwischen viele milliarden sein
ein wert an den googles mail zb nur in
der simulation herankommt in der echten
welt hat obama erst etwas über 16
millionen kilometer zurückgelegt wir
haben ende recht behält das werden wir
in ein bis zwei vielleicht auch erst in
drei jahren sehen in der zwischenzeit
bin ich aber mega auf eure meinung
gespannt was glaubt ihr
wann können wir uns in die ersten
selbstfahrenden autos setzen und am
steuer eingeschlafen
schreibt mir gerne eine jahreszahl und
in die kommentare vielleicht können wir
als schwarm intelligenz zusammen die
richtige vorhersage treffen
ich sage mal die ersten richtigen level
vier autos auf der straße gibt es
2021/2022 sagen wir mal 2022 vielen dank
an die gemeinnützige organisation
wissenschaft im dialog und das
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video das sie ist das zweite
video meiner serie zum thema ki im
wissenschaftsjahr 2009 10 im nächsten
video geht es um künstliche intelligenz
und ihren einfluss auf kunst und kultur
abonniert gerne meinen kanal wenn ihr
das nicht verpassen wollt und wie immer
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]